there's a misperception among many  people who are outside of Silicon Valley  that a great entrepreneur looks at a  market finds a problem and then comes up  with a solution to the problem those  really usually lead to mundane  businesses because anyone can figure  those out the truly exceptional  businesses are ones where the  entrepreneur by virtue of their  authenticity in a particular marketplace  is able to develop an insight a unique  insight about an inflection point in  technology that inflection point allows  you to build a new style of product the  challenge then is who wants to buy the  product so instead of starting with the  market in finding the product which is a  mundane business you want to start with  a product and find the market that  usually leads to a big business